La volta al món a peu, dia 239. Es fa molt estrany això de gravar sense el micro, és més còmode perquè no s'ha de connectar a res.
Nit molt humida, ja ho veieu aquí, extra humida, extra extra, però molt molt tranquil·la i relativament freda, en el bon sentit,
és a dir, m'he pogut tapar amb el sac tota la nit i he dormit d'una tirada, tu. A vegades me'n desperto amb calor, suant, etc.
Molt bé, avui ruta turística per a alguns jocs que he considerat que veia al mapa que eren interessants i ens anirem desviant de la ruta segons em convingui una mica.
Us presento el Giant Hawk Web, una planta molt important que heu de conèixer si veniu a Georgia a caminar.
S'assembla al Hawk Web, no sé com es diu en català, normal, que és el que és més petit, l'haureu vist, a Catalunya també està, crec, diries, és la versió gran d'aquesta, no?
Doncs no, no, no, encara que s'assembla, és diferent. El perill que té és que si sense volguer la trenques i la sàlvia de la planta,
que és com el líquid interior que deixa anar quan la trenques una branca, si aquest líquid toca la teva pell, fa que la teva pell perdi,
porta la seva capacitat de protegir-se contra el sol. Nosaltres ens posem crema de sol, però a part d'això, la pell ja té com una crema de sol natural, no?
Doncs el contacte d'aquest líquid amb la pell fa que perdi aquesta capacitat i, al mínim contacte amb el sol, pocs segons,
et surten unes botllofes terribles i unes cremades com si, jo què sé, com si t'haguessin passat amb un encenedor, eh? Literalment, és brutal.
Aquí no passa res perquè està per la carretera, que per cert n'hi ha per...
per tot arreu, però a vegades, quan vas caminant per prats alpins, has de passar a prop d'algunes d'elles.
A mi em va passar l'any passat i, bueno, no passa res, simplement anar amb compte de no trencar-la, però és perillosa.
M'acabo de trobar un home allà passejant per la carretera aquesta i hem tingut una conversa, bueno, no sé si li diria conversa perquè, clar, molt complicat, però bueno,
fent servir la paraula pèhid, que vol dir caminar, és la paraula clau que s'ha de prendre en tots els idiomes, doncs, bueno, més o menys ens hem pogut entendre.
L'he dit que venia des de Batumi, no l'he dit que venia des de Barcelona. Batumi, Borjomi, Tiblissi, ja ha fet. Uau, uau, m'ha donat la mà.
Després m'ha dit que tenia 93 anys. Molt bé, tu. Hi ha molts jausians que són molt malcarats, especialment a Tiblissi, gent que t'atén als serveis de botigues, el que sigui,
però després hi ha gent que és supermaja, superhospitalària aquí, sobretot a les zones rurals. D'acord, ahir no us ho vaig ensenyar, però vaig poder carregar el mòbil a dintre d'una església,
una petita capella. A veure si avui tinc la mateixa sort. Veig que hi ha un candau a la porta, per tant, malament.
El que us deia.
L'han parat aquests senyors. Com es deia? Your name? Aquest? No sé si ho ha dit l'alcalde. Però que em convida un cafè, home. Encantat, fa dies que no prenc cafè.
Què? Ah, ostres, la cigonya. La cigonya n'hi ha moltes per aquí, eh? És la que vam veure ahir.
Bueno, jo pensava que venia un cafè i m'han ofert sopa aquí. Són les 8, amb una mica de pa. Bueno, està bé, eh? Genial, genial. Me la menjaré amb molt de gust. Està boníssima.
La mantega, ells, que ara la puc provar. Boníssima, mantega. No l'he vist mai fer mantega, jo crec. Que bo, que bo. Genial.
Ostres, que bona aquesta sopa. No sé què porta, eh? Arròs? Porta arròs, però el sabor està, no sé, és com un... No sé, un formatge, no sé com dir-ho. Està boníssima, eh?
Ara em diuen que són grecs. Qui tan? De Thessalònica, eh? Calimera. Calimera, calimera. Això ja estic flipant.
No sé què diu, tampoc. Estic flipant que aquí hi hagi grecs. Estan pertot arreu, eh? Bueno, no sé què dir.
Gena, gena. Gena. Gena. Ok. Tinc amics grecs, a veure si m'ho poden traduir. I de Thessalònica, eh? Que és on vaig estar jo.
Ja està. Després m'han donat també pa, formatge... Espectacular. Però hi ha hagut un malentès, i és que abans d'entrar el tio em diu
Lari, Lari. Lari és la moneda d'aquí. I jo pensant, bueno, per l'esmorzar voldran alguna cosa de diners. Està bé, em sembla perfecte.
I després, quan estava assegut a la taula, em torna a dir Lari, Lari. I bueno, quan acabo ja, quan serveixen, em donen tot, i jo, bueno, vale, moltes gràcies, me'n vaig, no sé què.
Et trec la cartera, i amb el traductor els dic, quan us puc pagar? I llavors el tio, sofent, o bueno, sofent una mica, i m'agafa els diners i me'ls torna a ficar a la cartera.
I em fica, no? Em diu, no, no, no. Llavors, bueno, amb el traductor hem intentat... M'han dit, no, no ho tradueixis al grec, tradueixo al rus.
Bueno, en fi, que jo crec que ha sigut un malentès per la paraula. La paraula Lari...
Potser en un altre idioma que em servia ells, que no sé, deu ser quin, no sé si el rus o el grec, no sé, deu voler dir una altra cosa.
Deu voler dir, jo què sé, entra, vine, no ho sé, saps? Llavors, aquí hi ha hagut un malentès i no em volien cobrar res.
El que passa és que no crec que fossin grecs. Simplement pot ser que hagin viscut a Grècia a treballar, perquè a la zona del nord de Grècia hi van bastants georgians a treballar.
Aquest gos...
...ha sortit d'aquesta...
...aquesta finca.
No porto l'ultrason, després m'explico per què, a veure, tronca la pedra.
Sí, però no s'acaba de...
Porta un culleret, vull dir, que és d'ells, eh?
Tota la pedra funciona momentàniament, però després segueixen...
...segueixen venint, eh?
Vale, crec que ja està.
Sempre que dic crec que ja està, després mai està.
Desviació de dos quilòmetres, un per anar i un per tornar, per anar a veure uns petroglifs de l'època mesolítica.
Això he llegit.
Cap allà, a veure si val la pena.
Crec que no seran fàcils de trobar, eh?
Perquè estem aquí, a la part alta d'aquest congost, i estan cap allà, però cap a baix.
Llavors seguiré i baixaré d'alguna manera cap allà, a veure si els trobo.
Estan aquí sota, en principi, sota d'aquesta roca, segons Google Maps.
He suat la motxilla aquí, perquè no cal.
I a veure si puc baixar sense fotre'm de lloros.
Aquí tenim, pel que sembla, una de les, bueno, pintures, no sé com dir-li.
Aquí tenim com un home.
Vosaltres creieu que això és real?
Home, jo si el Google Maps ho fica, vull dir, serà que algú ho ha decidit, no?
Que això és històric.
A veure, a priori, hi ha gent que ha fet una mica de vandalisme.
Veig aquí una espècie de cèrvol.
Llàstima que la gent, la gent que ho ha tocat, eh?
A veure, intentaré posar-ho aquí.
Mira en pantalla això, de quina època, en principi, és.
Ni a més, eh?
I són les altres... no, pintures no hi diria, no?
Petroglifos.
Doncs mira, més animalons.
Bueno, tu, què, ha valgut la pena?
No tant per això, que és curiós, sinó l'entorn, que és bastant guapo, no?
M'he sentit Indiana Jones, per un moment.
Bueno, ara ja pujant...
Mira, ve algú.
Crec que no són turistes, que venen a veure els petroglifs.
Bueno, el que és flipant és aquesta extensió de terreny.
Aquests prats, alpins, infinits, increïbles.
Si segueixes cap allà, de fet, hi ha molts, molts, molts quilòmetres, no sé si més de cent,
en els quals no hi ha cap poble, ni cap ciutat, ni cap carretera, ni res.
I si segueixes, segueixes, segueixes, només trobes aquests prats, i al final arribaries a Armènia.
Increïble.
Ui, avui ja veig que quedarà el vídeo llarg.
Mireu què hi ha allà. No ho havia vist, venint per aquí i per aquí dalt, perquè estava com aquí amagat.
És com un refugi lliure, no? No ho sé, anem a veure.
Què és això?
El refugi lliure ho deia mitja enconya, perquè aquí...
Ui, ortigues.
Aquí m'estranyaria que hi hagués això, eh, però...
Hi ha unes taules aquí, s'ha d'anar cap a ella?
Què serà això?
A veure, a veure...
Oh, hi ha candau.
Hi ha candau.
Llàstima. Bueno...
També podria ser refugi, eh? Aquí.
Aquí sota, a dormir.
Apartar una mica les taules i posar la tenda.
Vaig a parar una estona a contemplar el paisatge i aixugar la tenda.
I per acabar-ho d'adobar, el llac aquest gegant, tu.
Aquesta zona de la Geòrgia és molt desconeguda i molt espectacular, eh?
Fins demà!
Vaig borrar el vídeo perquè pensava que l'havia pujat
i no l'havia pujat
i ja havia borrat alguns clips
per tant, bueno,
gravaré alguns clips a sobre per explicar el que havia passat
bastant cutret, però és el que hi ha
aquí simplement arribo a
la ciutat principal de la zona aquesta
i menjo
res, un dinar que no val mai la pena
amanida
i pollastre, molt normalet
les 4 de la tarda
missió secundària cap allà
anar a veure el pont de diamant
i el congost del riu
Herami
això és un congost
molt maco
en el que han posat un pont
de vidre amb un diamant al mig
cutre, guapo
què en penseu vosaltres?
en qualsevol cas, jo vinc des de l'altra banda del congost
perquè a la banda
on hi ha tota aquesta història
han posat també un parc d'atraccions
com zona d'hotel
resort
parc aquàtic
i venia de l'altra banda
i dic, bueno, des d'aquí podreu veure-ho
i m'he trobat aquesta tanca
i dic, ostres tu
quina mala fe, no?
entenc que és el negoci, però quina mala fe
però clar, dic, vaig a obrir per provar
suposo que està tancat
tu, si tenen la porta oberta
i no hi ha una senyal de no puc passar
doncs passo
aquí es veu
què us sembla?
a veure, si tota la muntanya
estigués prenent aquestes coses
diria malament, però
si només és aquí
no està malament
per què no he anat? perquè costava 30 euros l'entrada
uns 30 euros, dic, home
ja que he estat prou amb el tema
d'haver perdut el micròfon
i ja que he estat prou amb el tema
darrere d'aquesta muntanya
aquest turonet
hi ha un llac
sí
aquí hi ha un llac
Aquí dalt, hi ha un llac. I seria guapíssim acampar al costat del llac.
Perquè clar, estaries en altura, en un llac, veient la posta de sol, la sortida del sol, el paisatge tan bucòlic.
Normalment els llacs estan a baix i aquest està a dalt, no? Genial.
Bueno, què passa? M'ha donat per llegir les reviews al Google Maps d'aquest llac i hi ha aquest comentari.
Aquesta part tampoc va quedar gravada. El que diu la crítica és
Hi ha molts gossos grans a la zona, cuidant de les vaques.
Si el propietari no està a prop, estaran molt feliços de menjar-te.
Això és Jòrgia, senyors i senyors.
Tingueu-ho en compte. Com a contrapartida, hi ha un lloc interessant per acampar a 3 quilòmetres.
A les vuit i mitja aquí tenim el suposat lloc d'acampada d'avui.
Una església. No a l'interior, o potser sí, sinó més aviat fora, perquè he vist que potser l'herba està a una alçada decent.
Anem a veure.
Doncs no hi ha res més gravat. Ja està.
Llàstima perquè va passar una cosa bastant interessant, que és que em plantejo fer bivac al porxo de l'església.
No dintre, lògicament, però al porxo, perquè feia bastant de vent i així no havia de plantar la tenda.
I de cop i volta s'encén una llum i comença a parlar una veu d'una dona en rus.
Bé, jo interpreto que és rus.
Tenien allà una espècie de càmeres de vigilància connectades per internet, perquè hi havia una antena,
i potser algú m'estava veient des de casa i allò era el so de l'alarma. No ho sé.
Al final no vaig fer bivac allà i vaig plantar la tenda.
I bé, una nit amb molt de vent.
Molt de vent.
Em va costar plantar la tenda.
La tenda del vent vaig haver de tensar moltíssim, però va quedar ben plantada.
Super tensada, crec que és la millor plantada que he fet d'aquesta tenda.
I bé, demà al matí us explico com ha anat la tenda.
Demà al matí que és avui, no?
Ja us explico com ha anat la nit.
Resum, 45 quilòmetres, un cafè, he parlat amb 6 persones, 0 refrescs i m'he gastat 12 euros.
Ha sigut un dia bastant maco.
Em sap greu que el vídeo hagi quedat així.
Però bé, crec que s'ha pogut copsar com a mínim la primera part del dia que ha estat bé.
I aquests paisatges grandiosos, gegants, aquí al costat de la carretera.
No ho sé, aquestes valls increïblement amples.
Va ser un bon dia, va ser un bon dia.
Demà més i espero no tornar a l'Alià.
Bona nit.